you
[Music]
hello everyone welcome to the final
intern dr. a today we we have been who
was working with us all summer really
worked really hard on a new problem
so I want to it's my pleasure to
introduce Ben who's a PhD student at CMU
he works under the supervision of
Professor bhiksha Raj his current
research is focused on machine learning
for audio and previously he was a staff
researcher at ICS I at UC Berkeley and
he has done a lot of work on audio audio
understanding and multimedia problems in
the past and today he's going to talk
about his final internship project on a
cross-modal
audio search engine based on joint audio
text and bearing so with that please
welcome Ben thank you for the
introduction and thank you everyone for
uh for coming here I know that everyone
is busy so I appreciate your time if so
so so let's start with the present in
DES and introducing the topic first we
have that there are many many multimedia
and I will recordings that capture
everyday some of all of these recordings
carry information specifically in this
talk we're talking about the acoustic
information there are sounds there are
sound scapes there's information that
they lost what's going on in these
recordings and there are recordings that
are captured ensuring social media for
example where people typically will have
some words or descriptions to describe
what's going on in the content but on
the other hand there's also recordings
like from Amazon echo or alexa and these
devices also surveillance-camera
customer services recordings etc where
no one takes a time to label or a note a
what sounds or what audio it's it's in
the content so if we have these
recordings it's very complicated to do
search and retrieval so what typically
what people typically do is to approach
the problem with either text or audio
so let's say for example that we have a
query on the left and we have a pool of
information of audio and Associated
labels on the right if we take the the
query that text query cat we are going
to be able to retrieve the first and the
third recording because they're properly
labeled on this in the same way if we
have an audio that corresponds to Cal we
can retrieve the first and third and the
last one even though that last one
doesn't have the label of cat but
acoustically they are similar on the
other hand if we pass an audio and then
we are able to retrieve the Greek degree
now there from the pool but then in this
case we don't have tax right so in this
case we use acoustic similarity but we
don't have tach associated to that sound
so we don't know what is the content of
the sound until we actually listen to it
this might be easy for certain sounds
like cat but there are some other
acoustics and sounds that are more
complicated to decipher without some
context and there's also people with
disabilities who cannot listen to the
audio and infer the label so one
solution that is common in the
literature is to generate text metadata
for these audio recordings using
automatic speech recognition or some
event detection that is that there are
labels for sounds assigned to segments
of the recording now while we're try
what we propose here and which we try
this Homer was a cross model approach
and we aim for two main goals in this
approach the first one is to map audio
and text into the same sheer latent
space and that will benefit us because
then audio and text can be comparable so
if we pass a query that is a text or
another recording we can map it to that
joint space and find the neighbors a
that correspond to that recording the
second and most important I think is
that that the share spatial preserve
semantic similarity between the text and
the audio so typically as I was saying
the approaches will be designed
separately takes an audio
but here we want to combine both both
meaning the acoustic similarity and the
semantic similarity for example if we
have the the words violin brakes and
bile in place those two are semantically
speaking in terms of language similar
because they refer to a violin but if we
think of the acoustics of the sounds
that they will produce they are
different so we we we Hogan and we aim
that this joint space will find a middle
point to preserve the similarity
autotext and the audio at the same time
okay so the rest of the talk is about
the approach that we follow to create
this joint in space and how well those
were a joint representations world for
classification and also for retrieval
when it comes to related work we select
the three papers mainly three papers and
the first one is it was used to describe
an approach for search and retrieval
using takes an audio queries and
although this was this was a fast
approach it it was developed in an
independent way where takes an audio
word trained separately and then at some
point they were combined to assign a
score and then retrieve information
based on those scores data approach
didn't work with our vocabulary words
then the second approach from from
Malcolm a he created a semantic space
with text like a hierarchy and then on
the acoustic space they cluster audio
and then they linked those two spaces
but the this is this approach was it's
hard to scale because you need to you
need to create these disassociations and
and clusters and then on the third
approach we actually look at computer
vision and we found that there there's a
some papers that refer to image and text
and bearings where they try to approach
the problem in a similar way that we
described so the approach that we have
and and we we are going to use a closest
the
presentation is the Siamese Network the
same is network if the overall AVL
explained more more of the details after
the overall ideas that it will take out
even text one one on each head and it
will come you will take positive and
negative purse and the positive that
means that the text and the other
correspond to the same class and
negative pers means that the text and
the other correspond to a different a
different class so we will use this
pairs to train this network and then at
the end we at the top the loss function
is trying to make that the two
modalities that correspond to the same
class to be closer to each other and the
two modalities that correspond to in
class to be separate then at the bearing
stage once we have this man they will
train we will we will be able to feel
either audio tech text and then create
joint representations or embedding so we
can see those how the output of those
and bearings as an intermediate feature
that consider that takes on the audio
space so what we typically will feed to
the to the neural network are features
in this case for example we we use two
audio features which are MSS is a good
standard feature for for this task and
since we needed a vector we basically
computed the mean of the entire MACC
matrix corresponding to each of the
other recordings and then we created
mean vectors across time and the same a
similar approach with the text with the
text we use world to back what to back
if you are not familiar with that is a
technique to compare one word into a
numerical vector but those vectors a
preserve a semantic similarity so words
that are similar will exist in the
vectors with the close distance and
worlds are different will exist further
apart so the dimensionality that we use
for our audio and text features were 300
and this is basically the said setup
that we use for most of our work then
the the input and the configuration of
the siamese network
the following first we pass the feature
Society square before and we we assign a
zero or one depending if we pass in
negative or positive purse then this
network is basically the same that's why
they call them service is exactly the
same and they share parameters and it
was a simple DNN and the Apple was 1024
that is the dimensionality of our
embeddings there's one we have once we
have the invariance from atom varying
from takes this is raining time we're
gonna pass it to the head to the to the
bar well we do that to enforce the
similarity between modalities typically
well yeah so I basically carry on some
tuning with a static weak one layer and
then changing the number of nodes and
number of layers in powers of two and
after spend as a reasonable of time
tuning this was the best performance but
there's more more explanation to be done
okay so this is this is the most
important part of that of the neural
network because here that the liter to
basically work with this disk on both a
contrastive loss and the l2 distance so
the goal of this contrastive loss is as
i say to enforce that pairs that
correspond to a similar class are closer
and separate a different class to be
separate and it does it using the the
part that we see on the right which is a
margin DW is the distance for similarity
and when we when we have similar a data
we want the pairs we wanted to be close
within the margin m m is a hyper
parameter that we also to the problem is
that this actually during world for our
data so we try some other similarity
techniques a and distance and also
another loss function so at the end at
the end I want the common
perform the bass was the binary
cross-entropy
which also has a binary setup but now
that these dance I use the exponential
minus l1 or l2 the best one was minus l2
and here you have to think that the l2
and l1 as they are they have an
unbounded score right so it's very
similar there it's a small number and if
it's very large it can grow very high
but if we use the negative exponential
then we force the resistance to be a
number between two remember that if you
look at the plots it look like this the
exponential with a negative inside so if
they are similar we're gonna have one
and if they are different they're gonna
attend it would be a number close to
zero so now we have probably stick-frame
world pair and this one show to show the
best results that I'm gonna show later
in a different slide the emergency ABC
yes a yeah so if you get a so reminder
that we're passing first we'd see wrong
one so one will take care of one class
and the other one would take care of the
other class so why I can be 0 or 1 yeah
so 0 the second loss would be used and
then if Y is 1 oh it's a binary okay
yeah this a binary setup is finally for
both of them okay so we were with Percy
on one which is zero well it's can you
explain why did we use exponential yeah
so so so in this case as I was saying
with a which was this one because it
gives you a number from from from one to
zero but we could also use the cosine
similarity or any other combination but
we just try these combinations right but
certainly something else can be explore
for further distance and also for the
binary setup in the loss function yeah
but they don't there
no specific reason why we shouldn't try
the other ones so this is the combo that
we chose and then okay so now I just
explained how we train the network and
now let's go to the data and the
experiment so the data that we use this
is a data set that was released this
summer and it contains audio recordings
corresponding to free sound free
soundness is if you're not familiar is
basically like a YouTube for audio where
we can find sounds and tags and users
upload their their recordings we have
9000 recordings and the duration is up
to 30 seconds single channel now for the
text all of these audio recordings are
associated with a text level which were
chosen from the audio set ontology is a
hierarchy of 527 classes but for this
data say they only chose 41 from
different categories some of the class
examples are this ones that we have that
there can be instruments of animals and
so humans sounds from from just everyday
life and we explore the using the text
with single class levels and also
simulated noisy text by adding random
kind Gaussian noise with one or two
Sigma will explain this little bit more
in there in the future slide and
therefore classification our retrieval
we try this to model statistical models
would be most most of the of the work is
done with nearest neighbor basically
because well let me show the next slide
yeah sure it's 30 seconds and you
average all the features within
yeah without a 300 milliseconds and then
the audio it's a matrix that depending
how you extract the body if it's 300
it's representing 300 milliseconds we
just average over time and then we'll
get just one single vector for each
other recording sound and not yourself
right so the outers of the data set what
they did is that they chose 41 classes
from audio set no first first first the
computer right so but just the labels so
they took the ontology from obviously
not the data I just don't told you and
then they used those classes to download
out here for free sound and then they
they sort of like clean the data and
sound files but using the dictionary
exactly exactly they so the goal they
wanted to if you saw you from video it
tends to be very noisy and it's harder
to clean and also the rest of the
metadata is not precisely associated to
erased is a more complex problem this
one they try to clean the whole the
whole set up to make it a easier to
explore
then so the label is from the audio sets
so the other six has this ontology has
527 labels they chose 41 based on
whatever system they have
and once they had a label they went to 3
sounds they query those sounds collected
9000 recordings a distributed across the
41 classes and then there was a data set
more labels from that 41 a group of four
causes yeah good question so al vo said
actually has a multi-level problem here
they ensure that there is only one of
those 41 classes so each file is one
class carry one annotated class there
may be some other sounds there so if
they say that you have one recording
with drums it will be labeled as drones
however they may be a value in a violin
playing well in this case we'll have
violin let's say there's a birth
chirping that would not be annotated
but if you have drugs in violin and you
label it as drums only yes whatever
whichever is dominant yes the dominant
and for this classification is this case
should freeze out or you did the
labeling by yourself by running there
are yourself Pacific Casa no this was
done by there by the cool okay yeah this
is because that already was 200 it was
collected by me the people who are in
charge of free sound and the people who
are in charge of obvious it oh so they
basically team up and came up with this
one
yeah so they also have they do a
revision I don't know if they don't say
in the website or no it's just one who
they have three of them and then they
assign a number to of confidence whether
they actually detected the sound inside
a recording or not most of them are very
probably verify and actually accurate
but not all of them so there are high
chances
challenging exactly exactly
good so this is the beta so the first
experiment that we try was to see how
well the embeddings from the Siamese
actually work in comparison to just a
handcrafted mfc see features study
features and what we did here only for
this experiment was to train the Siamese
Network only using audio purse not text
evolved so we will just specify the
corresponding to the same class or pairs
of value corresponding to different
classes so we have all our training
audio we computed our M FCC's and then
we trained the Siamese Network then in
the embedded stage we pass all our audio
set over 9000 recordings we computer
them a CCS and then using the train
service network we computed the what we
call the audio solemn bearings so these
are embeddings that come intermediate
features or embeddings coming from the
train sorry miss network in the
evaluation stay a witch with this versus
a classification problem and then we
used our algorithm variance that we
created and do a classification task
trained and tested independently the
performance that we got here comparing
their handcrafted features and the
invariance is the following and there
are two main takeaways here help you go
through the slide one is that the MCC
sand and the embeddings from the from
the samisen a won't they were performing
comparably that means that the
discriminative power of the of the
embeddings was comparable to just a
handcrafted emesis the second is that we
use KN n and with we tune the deck a
parameter and also we use the SVM linear
and we tune the parameters inside we're
basically seeing that the performance
with handcrafted features and the
meetings were comparable we decided to
pay the KNN because it's it provides a
better framework for the idea of having
a neighborhood of embeddings
that way we that way it will be easier
to
to present their retrieval results later
on let's understand the number you have
50 ish percents classification accuracy
on 41 classes correct using can
ninety-nine thousand and five hundred
why did not you did not use something
more sophisticated than SVA material I
could yeah serious yeah so I yeah but it
wasn't that so the image so I try an
ability with two three four layers and
it was performing similarly to this with
the other embeddings the place that that
one was taking longer to train and also
there's so many parameters that can be
tuned that the Geo Cystic we just stick
to these two because it's easier to tune
and again the performance was comparable
I'm sure that if we will try a more
complicated and a neural network instead
of these two classifier we can do
performance yeah I have one question
about so you chose one mm cc-vector for
the entire sound clip it's quite average
did you think about other ways of
summarizing those mm CC vectors yeah
yeah so we can do super vectors or Ipek
there's any other approach certainly
because our only data about the dynamics
you of the signal you have is averaging
the deltas in the Alpha Delta strangles
right give something but not much right
yeah so so there can be better ways to
represent that matrix as a vector
actually later on we use better features
so we will show the performance we also
have chance to 51% say it's something
as the picking the classifier was not an
important point the point which we are
trying to make here is the embeddings
who they perform the same as that of
lawyers yeah your features are pretty
efficient right you know there was also
performing similarly it looks like a
future
yeah consistent across classes so if you
hope you here working something that's
futures so the bad thing here would have
been that the dark blue line was 20% and
the light blue line were 50% the next
bad that means that the that we are
doing with this show exactly we will not
be able to justify releasing this
context going through the extra full of
the computing embeddings
if we cannot be the mid simple of
Ephesus anyway so wait so now we have
the joint approach in this case now we
actually use Audion text first we take
our audio and text that the training the
training set we complete our vectors of
mlcc's and I will go to X for text and
then we train the thymus Network the way
that I described before so now we pass
all our audio recordings computer mlcc's
and compute the audio joint and bearings
right so disjointed medics again come
from a train network that was using
audio and text we did the same for that
text for the text we computed at X
vicious war Tyvek and then we pass it
through thus exactly the same train
thymus network and we compare our text
joint and bearings so now we have
intermediate representations for the
audio and for the text and then we the
st. the same set of where we have our
classification tasks but now we're gonna
show the cross modality explained
experiments cross smaller experiments
so first so here what I want to show is
how a the handcrafted features compared
to the joint and bearings in the top row
we have training only on their own the
means of the msec
and then test them on the means of msec
training test fault and then on the
right train only on the text which has a
water break vectors animals and train on
the water back and test on dmacc's so
the performance is forty nine point
seven which is similar to to the bars
that I showed you before and then two
point four is a random performance
because basically the features are
independent right we have any CCS and go
to break they are all related seriously
if you had all the dogs words you should
get a better than chance but we don't
have those yeah okay yeah anyway I have
to think of other one this room anyway
so these are the results when we
actually use the joint embedding so for
audio joint and bearings train and test
we get a slightly better performance and
then for for embeddings of text so we
train the nearest neighbor with with
embedding from text and then we test it
with imbalance of audio and now that the
performance was not random was actually
comparable that if we will have adjust
another audio setup okay so this one of
the of the main results will be actually
show that cross molality cross modal
embeddings can actually be used for
training test
represents better the audio or is based
mostly on audio you know yeah so it sees
that the it's in something very improve
on my intuition is it's because now
where are they in the text information
so we're basically another modality on
top and and that's that's helping us
improve this one and of course that one
has that help of the audio when we
trained the Siamese network so now we
are making the complicated and it's
perfect that's what we want
how four of them should be to be percent
exactly that would be the ideal case so
can we prove that the embedding is or
isn't biased towards the audio space
yeah if it's all equal then you can
conclude that yeah right yeah that's
we'll see we'll see but that's a good
question because whoa whoa I've touched
that topic that feels like so in order
to compute this results I just want to
show so a couple of interesting things
when it goes to training the the time is
network and one is that this this was
using the the uglier joint embeddings
audio with audio and then we can see how
the number of purse that we use actually
affected a performance depending how
much data will have this can explode so
it's important to know how the minimum
amount of purse that we need to do this
training then these are the results also
again with the audio audio joint and
bearings and this is how the performance
differ or by
with the different combinations of
Lawson similarity we ended up using the
one on the on the bolded okay so now we
go to that text so oh before before that
I added this extra row here which the
only difference is that now I added the
better audio features they come from a
sort of complex CNN architecture using
log metal frequency features and then a
path to the CNN and then it has seven
layers convolutional layers with max
pooling etc and then the output were
these features that we use that they
were also a vector that we pass to
Asami's and basically yes if we if we
have better features where are your
features we have better we can improve
the performance now this actually from a
paper data submission is from well as a
few members of our group and their
performance on obviously was comparable
to the state of theatre yeah so what do
we use this because we had this accident
so there's one author who participate in
both papers that work for Kari and this
one but but is not this first of all
yeah yeah yeah exactly
anyway so but the point is that if you
improve your features you also can
improve your embeddings and then so now
let's go to the cross morality with text
oh yeah yeah
so so there's one thing that I didn't
touch to it so so that takes here you
know that we have 9000 recordings and we
have a text label associated to each of
the recordings we have 41 classes so
that text is basically the same text for
further recordings in in training and in
testing right
does that make sense oh so that means
that the data that we'll have a training
time we also have that testing time
so what will Lex what we will expect
here is that again this this is a random
number because we're training or Nadia
and tested on war 2x these are
completely independent or related
features and think we're going to have
100 percent there because we have the
data the same data for training and
testing captain training cat cat cat and
interesting also they were Cat Cat Cat
Cat
all right but in reality they are not
like that the tags are cat cat kitten a
small kitten all of that right and then
the testing tags are slightly different
than that but in our case in this
experiment they were the same so that's
why you that you wanted oh but you
usually can pre-process the text disk
has been done it's a cruelty in
procession can speech recognition and in
yeah but if you do that you want to get
under percent you know what I'm saying
is if there is noise in the execute X it
not be interpreted so that's why we
exactly
thanks exactly so so then under these
premise we wanted to see how well they
do in various platform given that we do
have the same text in train they still
were passing it through the three
embeddings first so the same is network
first so a we were able to achieve 100%
in both it now this one we're training
with audio so we were computing audio
features with a vo-tech some Siamese so
we actually do not we see the late that
the text the label indirectly when
training the Siamese but not directly
because it's not in the training however
we still achieve 100% and then in the
other one it does make sense that is 100
because we have their joint and bearings
that are exactly the same internal test
and this trend is the same when we use
better other features now so a more real
case so we added noise to we added
simulated noise to the text we we
generated random Gaussian noise with one
and two Sigma's so that will mean that
is one signal is
more noise endure than the regional
takes pictures and two signals will be
even noisier and the way that we add the
noise is that when we computed I wore
two back embeddings we add the noise to
that vector and it would be different
noise to every single of the of the
9,500 recordings so we had on the
vectors controlled way we could have
just gone wild and change the text but
we didn't know we wouldn't know how
would reflecting this so that's why this
is the first entry if we also gonna add
random experts also eventually hizmet
will see that is that a fair way of
having noise because that assumes that
your words your very representation Maps
similar words yeah so that's how it
works so if you take cat and if we take
kitten and you compute word to vex for
both of them it's not zero there is some
finite distance and that distance is
small okay but if you take cat and if
you take bus and if you take the
distance is large now we could add some
random words to cat the cat set of tags
and then do the word to wait for that
but you would have control on the amount
of noise
yeah I'm just asking is that like is I
don't know how I was worth the way I
come up with this with this is that just
trained on so much yeah he's trained
this one is specifically straining the
Wikipedia and it's trying to estimate
how likely is that you have a ward in a
given context so these that is is there
any any reference that says the noise or
the distribution you get is somehow
Gaussian like you take a word like cat
and then no no look at yeah yeah yeah
okay just curious how this is computed
with words a very similar but very
different meaning like a captain Matt
for example hey you mean that the score
they would ya didn't work - that would
be like very close because the word is
seminar or is there some kind of
associated
context like the meaning is very
different so the business is different
yeah so the similarity semantic
similarity in the text will be learned
from from the context of the large
corpus that it was chosen so let's say
an example that I will make over now is
that you will say I pet the cat and I
pet the kitty so those two are very they
will happen very often in the same
context those two words so they will
exist in a very closed space in the word
to backspace when we come if you compute
similarity you can use any similarity
technique cosine similarity for example
and it will give you a score from minus
1 to 1 where 1 is the most similar very
basic we have an exactly the same word
and - well will be very different words
for example if you had cat and cats they
will be close but not exactly the same
right cat and Kitty etc oh yes sir
anyway so so okay so we just that with
just a noisy anyway so we just added a
noise here the way that we discussed and
now we do again that cross cross model
experiment now I am presenting this in a
different way so we have the four
combinations that we show in the table
before and here we have no noise noise
wee 1 Sigma noise with 2 Sigma so
anything in DISA and in the third case
adding noise didn't really affect the
performance of the joint imbalances but
adding adding the noise where we
actually have to test on text it
actually degraded a performance now this
can give us an idea how we could perform
work if we actually use it the tax or
some noise it takes right so this was
just to test the extent of the UNT
meetings
no we didn't know that any noise to the
audience because he was already there
were recording so they're already
acoustic diversity is quite wide okay so
then we saw very just to summarize this
is what we we use the joint emitting
from cross model classification and now
we want to we want to see how the
performance with retrieval so in the
retrieval case we basically have a
similar approach now we use that the
rest of your features we could we train
we use the same train siamese network
from before and then we created our
audio joint embedding Sangay again this
is a Disney plot which is basically a
mapping of that of the train vectors
audio train vectors into a 2d 2d plot
it's like applying PCA to a large
nationality and just reducing it in
order to plot it yeah Disney TS and
pronounce it anyway so so what we did
here first is to still do a qualitative
analysis will we pass a text query we
just define a text query and then we
pass it through an entire pipeline and
then I being work we have a texture and
embedding for that takes work and then
we we use the Train mirrors in able to
see which other neighbors right they say
in this case we use up X and we want to
see what are the audios the i/o
recordings that are near to that text
query so let me get you through this
table first this is for other vocabulary
words for words that are not in the 401
classes these are the text query that we
use and those are the retrieve results
from the audio pool so in this case we
have audio engineering so you bring
additional information here from the
written forward text working out the
vocabulary right means a label which is
not
but you bring a different additional
rotation how close is this to the
classes by one way by the training come
worked away right because they should be
solutions idea so then this yeah so that
it's had a vocabulary from our approach
but he seemed a vocabulary of the water
back users here we use the word applause
literally typed the word applause and
then from the pool of Allium bearings
these were the the retrieve results this
world our retrieve results which seems
reasonable for applause for Bark these
were the ones that we retrieve for gone
shop we'll retrieve these ones and I
mean that the neighbors were an audio
that had a gunshot as a label an audio
they had fireworks as a label and so on
and so forth but notice that if we will
have relied only on the distance of war
Tyvek just that existence we will have
retrieved these words but these are
difference because we are retrieving
based on text and audio distance so in
this case this means that is closer from
within the 41 classes right no that is
actually relevant to to the gunshot when
we use sign out of a capillary warlike
orchestral caster is not one of the 41
classes we actually retrieve this and
now the corresponding to cello are you
from violin etc when we use a more
abstract concept like house which is
also not in the 41 classes then these
are the ones I will retrieve with our
approach and this will be that ones that
we will retrieve if we will only look at
text take similarity okay so of course
the user can argue which one is more
useful in these more complicated cases
now we do the reverse we train we have a
text joint embedding spool and then
we're gonna use another query okay so
that's a reverse problem so in this case
a we have plus angle retry applause now
the these experiments were using one
standard deviation of noise and the
number of nearest neighbors that you
choose to bring the neighbors affect how
many results you get in this case we
based on the same number that we use for
nearest neighbors
which was around 25 we I downloaded an
ally of applause from free sounds tester
in and retrieve the embedding of
applause that was the closest one to
this audio so now we're receiving text
from that take somebody poo and we're
using IR do queries that I download it
from from the web from free sound same
with with bark it also will work well a
gunshot it didn't didn't bring the
gunshot as a wart but we didn't get it
and if I will juice all the audio
similarity only other similarity I will
retrieve these three but I will approach
with a joint Ameri now the texture and
the variance we treat this say we are
Carrigan orchestras aro vocabulary it
doesn't exist in the 41 classes so these
are the ones that I retrieve the text
and bearings and if I will have just
just the other similarity I will
retrieve this which is thing both are
reasonable now a this is how this is
using map for retrieval typically we use
mean average precision and K means that
when I retrieve the three top results I
should be able that in those three
results get the right one so that the
results look very close to
performance that we have with the
accuracy in classification but these are
slightly better because we are
considering that three yeah I just just
gave three because that's what they were
using of course if you increase okay
then most likely we're gonna get better
results right then so we're almost done
here then what was the next step so we
have that across molarity well show some
relevant results using the joint
embeddings we have that it also work
well with classification and and we
wanted to move forward to use it with
more complex have your more complex tags
so just to finalize we were we were
working on building a pipeline we will
actually used more complex idea coming
from first of all we use an AOL a
database that has a lot of query terms
we wanted to use real search queries we
pre process with text processing
techniques our our data set then we
created a crawl a crawler to collect
audio metadata tags and so on from
YouTube and and then we this part is
that is very similar to what I just
explained except for this one we also
included two models one that is gonna
generate synthetic metadata using speech
recognition and also some event
detection so that way we can have more
more tags and more information and then
we compute the features that we
described before train the Train the
joint embedding the siamese Network and
then use it for retrieval and ranking
now this pipeline was complete but we
didn't have time to actually run it
download thousands of videos and recall
this and actually test it we only did
some very small testing on this anyway
so the conclusion of this talk is that
the middle the method enabled the cross
modal classification as
as retrieval using using the audio and
text queries and the return results from
the Charlatans space since to preserve
some semantic between the text and the
audio I want to thank everyone for for
your attention and thanks Microsoft
Research and the acoustic group for
welcoming here it was a very nice time
and thank you very much to shave for for
mentoring me this summer
thank you
[Applause]
so you you have basic are basically
neural networks to encode post the audio
under the text why do you use the same
model to embed like two modalities
that's I think that's kind of strange
if I do this I will use like one model
to embed the audio and another model to
embed the heads under then try to pull
them together but here is really similar
to impose whatever you write so this
particular architecture the the new the
same is network works in a way that
these ways network its shares parameter
with these ones so this one has to be
exactly the same as this one um so I
understand in this way so if in the end
if this to model the same so you want to
make sure the outputs in the audio
embedding and the tax-evading are
similar then because you has used the
same in that Basin and then your audio
original audio vector hands or original
text vector will also be the same
because
neural network is cannot continue
embedding soul but so let me will give
it you a little bit with the problem
right so think about it like this in
some of these recording from spire
speakers we have a lot of audio right
some of this audio can be annotated some
of it cannot be right either you can
build a search engine using just audio
you can
using just the text but what we're
trying to do is we can make use of all
of this information to build a richer
search engine that is what we're trying
that's the motivation right and you you
are right you can actually clean the
network to just extract features have
extend audio at the beginning and then
do the joint information exchange later
right but this is one way of doing it
you can exchange information with the
base layer and then combine them sorry
combine them in the beginning and just
extract a joint similarity function but
you could also have separate layers and
then compute a similarity later but this
is more of a constraint problem which
will keep the vectors in the same space
so if the original MCC feature for the
audio is quite different from say were
to break fracture for the text then
there's no way to really make the
receiving there after the embedding yeah
so we'll be facing the same concept so
the more separate they are the harder it
is to to vote it will really close to
each other yeah I also have a work but
on the image and the text
retrieval tasks so we have seen done to
encode the image feature and another RR
and to encode a text feature and then my
use can only use the perception layer to
combine them together to account calculi
similarity and we also use it for
immediate robotics retrieval so when I
see this is here the parameter size it
cause you to compare both approaches
both are valid but I don't know which
one works better so we write this
because we thought we borrowed this a
lot from image and text search image
search people have done that better
third paper I cited was actually the
motivation for his work yeah so this one
if you treat them separately you will
end up with two neighbors one that it
treats the text and one that we said
that you measure the area in this one is
the exactly the same network to fit the
vo-tech so you can treat them separately
or the same way thanks question in which
one is better so we don't know yeah
because I'm good violence in terms of
the training Nathan like you have a lot
of to do but very little text or the
other way around and if you have this
they shared then you can be harder to
Train probably yeah that effect so if
it's balanced and quite be easier to
Train we don't know that so that's an
experiment definitely enough because I
like the idea you said because you know
and then might be better at encoding
information from the text and a
different network might be better
encoding information from audio for
example yeah yeah in the text to make
you only lost the sense of sequence sure
yeah so it is heavily barsaat thoughts
since the synopsis or instead of so
using the word the work also in this as
a as part of the base network might help
training jointly members that might also
be here yeah so we basically abstracted
out or separately that feature
computation here which is different from
from earlier takes but something needs
where they actually connect here that
CNN and he just issuing a new icon later
here and this one is also independent
well you need an alignment stage just
needs to be shared by both I mean in a
way worth to Becky's already doing
something yeah and same with the use of
CNN features you basically have two
machine like to neural networks that are
separate you know except game there but
there's not Jackie frame that's the
problem right right but I mean they can
be to entrain but I also understand this
past in this way you need your face and
but have neither capacity because
essentially you are learning
featuring betting on a much matter space
so you are in that your input space a
union of the audio invaded space under
the text embedded space so in this case
if you want
you like you have want to have higher IQ
than you your base and should have
larger capacity than and then the way if
you just want to tune your basil and and
the audio space and another piece of
that one the tech space so there are a
lot of ways of doing this experiment the
way we started is to actually start from
the last way we collected all these tags
and everything we're not going anywhere
we realize that it's really hard to
train the siamese network to actually
convert into something then we realize
what you should simplify the problem and
this is how we started and we are
presenting the final flow and it looks
more controlled enough and we don't know
how the real times will perform it might
just not work at all
so we don't know we still evaluating I
am NOT much concerned about separate
training of the future expect us the
cause of the more correlated are they
the bigger is the risk of training them
separately but we just mentioned that
they're kind of quite different so to
incan correlated sets you can train them
in it separate you without losing much
of accuracy and we can see in this
another all your tasks as well and for
work to make actually brings a whole lot
of prior information yeah it's more
those the tick what is the coolant of
depth to what do you are you or do you
think I think I think in my work the
tech to invent the text we do not use
kind of work to make preaching the work
to back back sure we just but in our
case we are in very simplistic so each
word is just like yeah so your basic
well the other one thing so you have the
work to make within a part of this
network yeah you you can sing in this
one we can do that but it's like a big
beast again like I said yeah we also
discuss about converting this into a
more complicated Network
and there's work for attention they they
take the audio and they also take text
for the CNN do you need a sentence that
says man this is some this
is supposed to rule in the courts
computational requirements l know that
with this super computation I think it's
about getting convergence to this yes
yeah is really hard because if you will
accomplish that what you don't know
where you're going all right
[Applause]